this is a production of cornell
university
thank you mary
um so hi everyone thank you very much
for being here i'm doctor daniela
vergara i'm the emerging crop specialist
from the harvest new york team
at the cornell cooperative extension
and uh it is a great honor and pleasure
to introduce mandy kerr who is the lead
from the global hemp association i've
met mandy maybe a year ago or so i
wouldn't be talk we've been talking um
very often lately because she runs this
incredible platform
that uh she's been able to get people
together from all over the us and
internationally
um and she runs all platforms regarding
camp so
if you want to know someone who's
processing fiber or grain or cbd or
who's growing it or anyone here or
elsewhere in the world mandy is your
person to contact she has an incredible
list of people from
seat to sale everywhere in between and
processing everywhere in between and i
think i am a big admirer of what she's
done from scratch because she did it
from scratch
not only because she's able to connect a
bunch of people and so i totally
recommend to go to her website and to
visit her website but also because she
is really good at knowing what other
people know and not knowing what she
needs to know like i need to figure out
this who do i need to contact so i
really really um want to highlight the
global hemp association and all of the
work that mandy has done
and with that um mandy please take it
you're awesome i'll have to pay you
later for that intro that was very very
nice and thank you thank you very much
for having me you guys i'm really
excited so again like daniella said my
name is mandy kerr
i started the global hemp association a
couple of years ago really with the
focus of creating a platform where we
could connect um
the entire supply chain and i really
went into this with a focus of
um the industrial applications and fiber
where there were a lot of organizations
that were really focused on cannabinoid
or siloed by state or industry such as a
building building organization or hemp
feed coalition i really wanted to create
a platform where we could start to
connect and bridge those gaps between
those organizations and between
universities or
entrepreneurs in the industry and so
i've hosted a number of different um
interviews i host eight to twenty a
month where really again our focus is to
highlight people that are doing it right
in the industry and give people an
opportunity to
to educate and promote what they're
doing
um and so
our mission really is to build a secure
and transparent trusted infrastructure
that encourages collaboration and
connection between farmers processors
manufacturers and marketers um and then
we focus like i said on all aspects of
the of the industry but really have
taken a a fiber focus first in this
initial round and with that we're doing
a number of different seed trials and
putting different different research
programs together to support the
industry's growth and so i'm happy to
talk more about what we're doing
specific but i really wanted to kind of
just go over what we're seeing as far as
the industry trends um so here's a cool
little graphic
just kind of explaining what
anticipation is for the industry um
getting away from so much of the
cannabinoid production or small-scale
seed production really moving into a
growth in the fiber market with an
expectation of 18.6 billion by 2017.
um this is pretty good overview
it's kind of funny as i started this
presentation and put it together
a couple of months ago or started
talking about it it's amazing the topics
that have come up just naturally amongst
our groups and so i really leaned into
global hemp associations advisory team
we've built a team around all different
aspects in the industry and leaned on
them about our global trends and what
we're seeing and so this is not just
feedback from what i've seen
specifically but definitely leaned into
our teams
in north america the growth of the herd
market has really been been booming
really focused on animal bedding and
hemp crete um for those i'm not sure
who's on the call but herd is the woody
core within the hemp stock um and that's
really taken off and really i lay that
or put a lot of contribution for that to
the processing that we have available
within the industry and where that sits
as far as the quality of processing
that's needed
um the price itself has increased at 75
percent over the last year and really
due to the shipping costs from china and
europe um it's been very exorbitant um
hemp bast or the fiber is really being
used for insulation and to replace
fiberglass glass that market's growing
very quickly both in the automotive
industry as well as the building
industry the substitutes for bio
composites and uh insulation fiber
markets have
also learned the hard way
there's a lot of fiber being grown right
now and a lot of our herd producers or
processing facilities are starting to
see a backup of
fiber that is not able to be moved into
the market due to the poor quality of
fiber and so we're really realizing that
no matter what the cost is our big
markets are not going to open up and
they're not able to come in and purchase
until we get a consistent quality for
inputs
and so we're seeing a lot of backed up
unusable fiber that's going to need to
be processed and so
we're processed again and it's that
second and third phase of processing
that we're still struggling to see
especially here in the united states
biocomposite pellets and biocomposite
products are evolving slowly but
carefully
there's really a dynamic opportunity
the dynamics and opportunities are
becoming better understood by processors
and distributors
which is really you know i think
a unique situation that we have when we
talk about um market demand we're
starting to see consumers are
understanding the value of these
more sustainable products and so we're
starting to see a much bigger drive the
economics of the hemp crop are also
becoming better understood with a lot of
research being done and i'll talk a
little bit more about what i'm seeing
later on as far as the research that's
being conducted
and the focus in industry has really
shifted to those data points and less
around
being able to do it ourselves but really
recognizing the need for data for
scalability and then in north america
textile fibers are slowly evolving into
the market
nowhere near as fast as it's been
expected like i said that secondary
processing or
carting and de-gumming is really
something that the
the united states is lacking we're
lacking the equipment and or the
in china we're seeing a lot of chemical
use that we just don't have or hand hand
processing that we just don't have and
can't compete with here
so we'll just take a little bit longer
to get there but it's definitely a
viable market you see a lot of companies
like patagonia that just released an lca
on the hemp fiber that is proving much
more sustainable than these other
products and because of that obviously
we're seeing large brands you know
really get behind the value of the
the hemp in their in their materials
and then hemp fiber used to strengthen
concrete and sequester co2 is becoming a
huge area of interest in our markets um
you know
hemp really is at the forefront and i'll
mention this again here in a minute but
hemp is really at the forefront of these
conversations around sustainability and
esg scores and so looking at the life
cycle analysis and being able to lock up
that carbon in the hemp crate for or in
the concrete for 100 plus years becomes
a very valuable carbon credit as this
you know the greenhouse gases and
addressing the carbon sequestration you
know hemp is more and more at the
forefront of those conversations
and then many new products are
evolving into the marketplace such as
reinforced rods and concrete made from
vast fibers
still there's a lot of rnd that needs to
go into this but proving to be stronger
than steel
and then of course you know adding that
extra value on top um you know when we
talk about the carbon avoidance and
sequestration
so to date uh feed ingredients hemp feed
ingredients the market is not improved
yet by the association of american feed
control officials or asco and fda or and
the fda center for veterinary medicine
so in montana has really let the charge
on our hemp feed and
markets for grain and feed
and so this is an area where global hemp
association like i said we've really
focused on the fiber aspect and really
lent to collaborating with organizations
like hemp feed coalition but in 2021 uh
the governor of montana signed in a bill
that authorized hemp food ingredients
for commercial animal feed and then
they've worked diligently um with the
hemp feed coalition and led by ind hemp
that charges really led by ind hemp to
bring hemp um animal feed into the
market which will really open up that
grain market that is really stifled
right now
by a lack of lack of end users or
ability to feed
um and then like i said earlier hemp is
really at the forefront um when we talk
about you know
what is this value and where do we see
the market going
hemp is at the forefront of these
conversations around sustainability and
carbon um and it's so much more than you
know even the material that we're making
but the the entire process at which it's
being um manufactured is more and more
sustainable or is being considered to be
more and more constant sustainable
people within the industry are really
focusing on it
um and then a complex regulatory
environment for production of sales for
cannabis products um and additional
layers of difficulty in project
projecting excuse me domestic markets
demand the market demand and expected
levels of for production of production
wow i'm struggling on this one
for those producers interested in
exporting cannabis into foreign markets
the difficulties are amplified so again
you know as far as like the overall
global market um the legislation and
policy or lack thereof around the
cannabinoids and health and wellness
products is really stifling the market
for international especially
international trade and then we talk
about research trends kind of like i
mentioned previously um
i'm seeing a ton of focus in the
industry on this need for true data and
there's a big difference
that we've noticed in farm trials that
are conducted by farms and research
trials you know and when the data is
collected both very valuable but both
very you know very critical i guess to
be done correctly and so the value that
we're seeing or what we're starting to
see a lot is this need for scalability
and the need for scalable data and so
making sure that data is is collected
correctly and therefore you know the
government is really getting behind
funds or
making funds available for research and
infrastructure builds so that we can
better understand and scale our industry
and so i just made a few comments here
last year last year there were
two pretty good size grants given out um
one for global hemp innovation center
and one down in the kentucky area and
i'm not positive who's part of that um
conglomerate that are you guys
i don't know if cornell is part of it
you are okay anyways um yeah so great
opportunities here to research and study
the plan and then just recently um
secretary vilsack announced on february
7th the
um
one billion dollar partnership for
climate smart commodities and for
expanding markets and during his
presentation specifically called out
hemp multiple times for the climate
smart um commodities
and so and again for providing that
additional rotation crop or additional
crop to our rural farmers and supporting
rural rural communities so it really is
at the forefront um this is just the
most recent a couple of recent um
i guess images that i just put out here
one is from the
usda survey that they just published
about acres that are being grown it's
really interesting when i look at this
graph it looks like our industry is
doing really well and then there was
another graph i was going to put on here
that or another image that i was going
to put on here that
shows acres or states that are actually
growing for fiber and it's such a small
small market and so with that i wanted
to show we've got a lot of hemp
production that is happening on and when
i say a lot it's significantly less as
you can see on the graph
the other graph here compared to what we
saw in 2019 and 2020 for projected
growth um but
i
with that i want to add here on the
other image you can see the number of in
blue or the number of licenses that were
issued to grow hemp and then the orange
line is the number of acres that were
actually grown for him or reported to
have been grown
and we're expected this to scale
significantly um same same group whitney
economics beau whitney has done an
incredible job at the economic side of
this industry and he's projecting 10
million acres by 2020 by 2030 and so um
or at least the demand that's needed
right and of course there's obviously
concern about
how we're going to scale where
seed production and so forth um but it's
definitely you know that the demand for
the material is definitely becoming more
and more um obvious and relevant
with covid and now war and supply chain
issues and transportation issues so as
far as globally i just kind of wanted to
touch on a couple different areas across
the globe and what we're seeing um at
present europe cultivation cultivates an
estimated 25 percent of the world's hemp
mainly in france
um followed by the netherlands romania
in total at least 20 countries cultivate
hemp and europe and european continent
and so um they've done a great job we've
got a number of members that do fabulous
especially at their seed production
they've had years to
you know work on this a lot of equipment
has come over from the from or into the
u.s has come over from europe
but reality is is the acreage at which
they'll be able to supply seeds for us
long term is significantly smaller
compared to our demand and so we've
really got to be able to
um stabilize our our production and our
our seed cultivation
um china remains the world's largest
hemp producer for fiber um
they've done a great job most of our
textile fiber pretty much all of our
textile fiber comes from there and or
india but china is definitely leading on
textile production
um they still have illegal you know hemp
is still for cbd production is illegal
in the majority of their country but
years ago they legalized it and put
government funds behind it for its
antimicrobial factor in textiles
india loosened restrictions on
hemp-based productions in 2021 allowing
hemp seed hemp seed oil hemp seed flour
and introduced as general ingredients to
food products
japanese regulations remain highly
restrictive with regards to cannabis and
cbd industry is wholly driven by and
supported by cbd
colombia continues to be the leader in
latin america it's kind of interesting
there's a number of members here that
have really pushed and gotten involved
down in in colombia um which is pretty
cool regulations approved legislation
reform in 2021 and allows cult fade
cultivators to export flower grown into
the country grown in the country canada
is of the biggest importer for colombian
hemp in the world
so i think that that's a pretty you know
fascinating statistic when you look at
international trade argentina chile and
brazil are reformed regulators in all
reformed regulations in 2021 to allow a
more favorable flow of cannabis products
into their borders
none of these three countries currently
have agricultural programs allowing for
hemp to be cultivated but
but have patient-focused medical
programs
um one thing that we are definitely
starting to see especially as genetics
are starting to become more stabilized
and really evaluated are the um you know
the programs are definitely opening up
for um
big agriculture and outdoor cultivation
and then african countries
it's mind-boggling to me how much i hear
about
both financial transfer and support into
the african countries as well as the
cultivation for or as well as the big
agriculture support um even as much as
bringing you know irrigation water or
um pivot you know pivot lines into
africa so numerous international
companies have successfully applied for
licenses in zimbabwe in 2021 and we
expect government support that is being
committed to the hemp program will
continue to keep zimbabwe as a leader of
the african cannabis markets
um
and then that's pretty much it i'll open
it up for questions if you have
questions or
anything like that a touch back on
global hemp association we host 18 8 to
20 meetings a month that are similar to
this where we
um offer questions i work with daniella
she's been on a number of different
times and some other staff from cornell
but i invite you guys to check out our
youtube chat page or
listen to any of our 400 posted
interviews with different executives on
our youtube or or any of our podcast
channels
so
that's about it
marie do you have any questions or does
anybody else have anything that they'd
duh you said about montana and the
grain
so their governor
said that you know they could use grain
however if they feed it to animals don't
they run the risk of that animal product
milk meat whatever
being rejected by other states
yeah so they can't sell it on
it can't it can be sold into their own
cattle but it's an animal but it cannot
be sold across state lines into
commercial production
yeah
not yet
so that is right not yet sometimes it
does take but i just wanted people
listening to know that like you know
intra state
interstate um differences are often you
know a problem
yeah i would say that that's that's been
the biggest
heartache especially as you see the
studies that have come out on animal
production i saw one that was just
released today from the
um national hemp association about eggs
and the omega-3s and omegas that they're
seeing in eggs because the chickens have
been fed hemp
um
hemp feed yeah actually i asked this
yesterday so what does
you know canada certainly
you know we buy a lot of for human
consumption a lot of our grain hemp seed
comes from canada
what do they do in terms of
testing and some other things to can't
we just follow along with some of that
yeah and i think that they have what
we're seeing now is they want to
understand what that buildup is right
after we've consumed so much of it what
is the build up for us and then what is
the buildup for our animals and so i
know that takes time and the re the
studies that are required are hundreds
and thousands of dollars and so
you know raising enough capital and then
ind hemp has really funded a lot of that
so
i think a matter of time
yeah any other questions for anybody i
don't know where anybody is at as far as
in the industry i recognize a couple of
faces or a couple of names
mandy this is gianna stegny i'm one of
the co-hosts today
i work with cornell cooperative
extension
i'm curious about the insulation panels
yeah i contact you offline can you give
me a potential businesses to contact
absolutely absolutely and i'll give a
shout out to one that's really leading
the charge they did an incredible job on
a recent crowd fund raised a few million
dollars in a week or so a hemp a texture
they're out maddie mead is in idaho um
heath building uh hemp insulation or
doing hemp insulation with a bat wool
like a wool insulation
and
he actually started in hemp crete and
now has shifted over to the insulation
um but they've got a pretty good
facility going in i think they broke
ground last month and have partnered
with ind hemp on supply so
i've got a good supply going
and then if you're looking for the
international we've got about a handful
of those as well
thank you yeah absolutely
i have
two loaded questions i like it
okay so the first one is
how do you think
if you were to create
a roadmap
for
the us to become the leader in hemp
production
and processing in the world
how would that be that's my first
question
and then my second question is
where are you going
short term and long term with the global
hemp association what are your
next steps your goals and where would
you want to be
in five years
okay road map is a loaded question
and and i'll be honest i think that
there's some that i'm not sure i
personally know
um but definitely collaboration you know
we see big brands are not willing or
able to come on until we have a more
secure supply of
um
input that is diverse right that we can
pull from different territories i
definitely see you know if we're talking
about seed or production the northern
states have done a really good job at
grain production you know the heartland
um the midwest is going to do really
well with the automotive industry and
volume of production because it you know
as we move into a rotation crop we're
adding it as a rotation crop um
we're going to see bigger volume i think
the oil or energy sector and and you
know the automotive industry i think
that we have to keep in mind that our
facilities are going to be close to
where our end manufacturers are for cost
um of the of the fiber cost of
transportation
um
is that answering your question do you
have any other like what specifically
about the roadmap
i'm just curious about
how do we take the business from these
other countries and get it ourselves
like what is
what is
what is it that we need to do
and also i'm thinking also about you
know like my priorities for my job like
what is it that
i need to focus on so that we have the
business here and not
elsewhere internationally
um i'll be i'll be honest when we talk
about states states have done a really
good job at figuring out what's going to
grow well in their state potentially
right there's some that are a little bit
different especially in our lower states
but on a nationwide scale trying to
really bring together existing data so
that we understand what is
what is sustainable right we as an
association immediately are focusing on
national seed trials with a goal of
creating scalable data you know so that
we can hit multiple areas across the
country
however for new york right understanding
well let me back up for a second there's
another piece to this you know the
united states has to compete on labor
cost that other countries don't have to
compete on and so being very serious
about bringing in
ai or robotics or technology that can
help to you know
solidify the consistency you know
provide a better consistent
product for inputs as well as our
outputs increase our profit margins you
know make it so we don't have to compete
with the labor costs i think that that
puts us on a much more even
playing field with someone like china or
india or even in um you know our
southern states where or
say like latin america right where labor
cost is just not as much of a concern as
it is here in the united states and so i
definitely think ai or
technology has to be added into
you know some
less typical um
industries like manufacturing and or
farm and agriculture
marie oh let me ask one answer one more
question about the the long-term goals
of gha
initially we're really focused on our
research and building a research arm
really moving into being able to
understand how
how product is processed what the value
of the product is and then moving it
into end products or in manufacturing
you know we have a lot of products that
are being manufactured when i say a lot
say a hundred different products but if
this said 20 to 25 000 or even 50 000
products can be made from hemp we're
going to start seeing a major impact or
opportunity for ip and for
new development that just isn't
understood so in the next few years
really focusing on building consumer
demand and creating or helping to
participate in that standard development
or grading process so that we can you
know
have a better consistent input at our at
our manufacturing
i'm going to ask about the organization
um i
i tried on a blog to have sort of like a
matchmaking thing
so whether you want to buy product sell
product
even look for a job hire someone in the
industry whatever and you know it was
just like a little too small
geographically do you guys have anything
like that like a matchmaking kind of
place for
that to happen i mean other than what
goes on in your personal head about uh
you know who's doing what where who
needs what
is there a way folks can find
aha
haha i'm so glad you asked and that
wasn't even prompted
so um as part of the association i
the whole reason i did this is i i
attended an event one time and over and
over again i heard people making the
exact same mistakes i was holding an
extraction some
crude basically um slurry that was
extracted with a water-based extract
water-based technology or solution
and
costing pennies on the dollar and over
and over again i saw people making the
same mistake with extraction technology
and there was nowhere for them to go and
find who's in my area who do i know and
so as part of the association i wanted
to build a platform with outside of me
or outside of anybody on our team you
could log in and find out who's
processing who's in your territory
what are they doing what are their focus
is you know i've interviewed now 480
executives and published them all on
this platform and so this is our hemp
hallway i branded it as the hallway so
all organizations can come together log
into the platform and make connections
and then um so this kind of works like a
typical feed
i go live this is connected to our
facebook page we post different articles
or things that we share here's upcoming
events you can get on and actually make
posts as well but then i've actually put
everybody that's logged into the
platform on a map and so i can search
within a territory or a state and kind
of see who else in my state is
registered what do they do are they
processing are they you know in
different texts say in a textiles
industry and then same with different
opportunities i could post if i'm
looking for a job it looks like somebody
just recently posts looking for a
strategic or looking to be hired
then in our media center i publish all
of our interviews and then also on our
youtube channel so you can get in and
search say a carbon meeting
and you can see all of our carbon
meetings that we've hosted in the last
couple of months
as well as any articles that we have
made may have published
um
and then opportunities oh sorry i did
opportunities already what was i looking
at organizations so these are all of our
companies as well and so you can do the
same thing get on here these are all
companies and now remind you these are
all companies that have logged in or
people that have set up their profiles
on hemp hallway and so um
yeah it's created this this network or
community where outside of
you know calling me or picking up the
phone you have a place to say who's who
within the industry across the world
so yeah
and you can actually send messages and
connect so you can see here jeannie
ingles logged on today
she's actually created an awesome hemp
creep product or hemp create block and
just recently received a pretty good uh
grant from the epa but now you can send
her a message and connect with her
directly from our platform
so yeah
i hope that that answers questions
yes thank you
absolutely
are there any other questions about
trends or things we're seeing and just
so you know please feel free to reach
out to me at any time we have a great
team of people
um i could show you too log on i'll
share our youtube channel right here
with you so that you have it
but feel free to you can log on their
membership for us it's fairly
inexpensive for what we offer but we're
always looking for support so that we
can do our national seed trials and
really
help provide scalable data
just to touch back on why we're doing
our national seed trials is over and
over again as we are building
relationships with large brands and i'll
use levi's as an example you know
they're they're
currently purchasing from china it's
getting harder and harder to import or
you know or work with them for a number
of different reasons
um and
so they're looking for a way to come
over to the united states but can't
until they know that they can they can
really hit scale for their their inputs
and so our goal is to be able to provide
that scalable data that then we can
share with universities and individuals
to
you know
more accurately make decisions about
where processing is going and what we're
doing
so yeah
i don't know if anybody else has
anything
how
do you see us
at cornell
collaborating with you how do you see um
us going you know like
two-way direction that benefits us how
do you see that
oh absolutely um
i think the association has done a
really good job at talking to the
industry
now i really focused when i approached
this industry i approached it from
my the people the people are actually
what drive my passion i'm really
passionate and i'm really good at
connecting and so i went after it and
learned what the industry needs and then
have a confident pla i i'm confident now
our team is confident now with a number
of resources and our advisory board that
we've built that we can bring a funnel
you know to an organization like cornell
so that we can then move products into
market provide accurate education and
information
work together on grants to fund or bring
people that are ready you know to the
market um as well as collaboration on
education
um i host a number of these
i've had
i think 7 000 people log into our
meetings in the last six months and so
it's given us a good audience or network
to be able to reach them you know both
in person as well as over you know
digital platforms and so
you know being able to also co-share and
collaborate on data now as we collect
neutral data i want to make sure our
data can withstand major peer review and
then in turn being able to build on that
data so we can save on resources and
things like that
i feel like i'm in the hot seat usually
you guys i'm this is flipped around and
i'm the one asking all of the questions
and so
um but yeah i think all in all you know
when we talk about processing in the
united states there's major opportunity
lots of processing facilities are coming
on board
um
it's going to be a race to the bottom in
the commodities market and i know that
those are processing right now are
really trying to keep price up and so
being aware as building building
facilities you know what is that what is
that in market that we're after and and
how do we add that added value to the
hemp stock so that it can be so you're
successful so that you are sustainable
because if we're processing and spending
millions of dollars to sell into animal
bedding long term eventually animal
bedding will be that low hanging fruit
for a high-end textile processor that's
going to be you know producing major
volume and then bottom of that market so
keeping that in mind on that
you know as we start to grow what is
that tipping
point so yeah tim do you have any
questions you have anything
i kind of came in late so i
don't but that was very informative um
i know
now i'm on the hot seat
but um yeah
awesome awesome awesome yeah i think i
wanna
go ahead janice i'm just watching the
clock yeah that's me too i was gonna say
i want to thank you for your
presentation that was that was great
so um but we do need to move on to our
next speaker now
i love it well thank you guys it was
wonderful like i said if anybody needs
anything you look me up on youtube and
or the the global hemp association we've
got a great team to connect and happy to
to provide resources
and i appreciate that yeah your team at
cornell has been fabulous daniella thank
you very very much you're great
so our next speaker this morning is john
hanchar
and john is
a farm business management specialist
with cornell cooperative extension
on the northwest new york dairy
livestock and field crops team
john um
focuses
in the areas of farm economics and
management
his research focus has been on
developing applied economic analysis to
evaluate changes in practices and or
technology
uh to help inform
decision-making current projects involve
economics of growing mulching barley in
new york state
economics of growing industrial hemp in
new york state
and best benefits and costs of precision
farming technologies
so john has been our economists that
have helped us evaluate
uh some of the cbd growing uh projects
that larry smart and savannah who spoke
yesterday have been involved in
so with that john i'm gonna turn it over
to you
and he's gonna talk about risks in the
hemp industry today
uh yeah so my name is john hanchar
uh we're working on a northeast
extension risk management education
project uh here in new york and also in
vermont
uh lindsey paschall uh who's on
maternity leave right now has been the
primary uh person that's been
that brought us together and and put
this project together
and we want to report on that today
and i think just for context a couple of
things that mandy mentioned
uh just now regarding uh data
data points uh forming expectations
uh
things like understanding quality
standards and other things
have all come out of uh this work and
just
real quickly that you know the the
framework is uh
farmers face various risks or this
value chain face
various risks production marketing
uh labor legal and financial
and
what we concluded from the work so far
is that
marketing legal
and financial are the top three uh risk
areas of priority
for the participants that uh were
involved in our in our work
and they really identified
three things as far as the uh
needs or
what
would benefit them
for reducing risks in this industry
to make it more likely that they'll
decide to enter the industry and then
also be successful
and so those were the
right off the top that the value of
information and whether it's knowing
standards whether it's knowing the legal
aspects whether it's understanding the
production uh
possibilities
that was uh
the most important thing that was was
mentioned by our our participants
uh secondly uh the uh the idea of
contracts and it falls into
the idea of information but
mentioned uh quite often in a very
specific way and i know that mary and
others at cornell have put together
good resources for uh forming contracts
and making sure that they're executed
properly
but it
seems like maybe there's a need to
improve how we
get this information out there and then
the last thing is uh cooperatives uh the
value possibly of forming cooperatives
and
to see if they can help
uh reduce the risks
so i'm gonna start uh the presentation
the lindy pre-recorded uh back in
december
and i thank her every week
it seems for uh for doing this and uh
we'll uh we'll get started okay
risk associated with the new hemp
industry
hemp growers and processors will supply
better
into the risk associated with the hemp
industry from five sources of
agricultural risk
these five sources include production
marketing financial constraints
legal concerns and labor issues
our planned project outcomes
to increase hemp growers and processors
understanding of risk and increase
awareness of risk faced by the supply
chain
for small growers and processors working
groups to analyze risk by assessing and
evaluating alternative strategies to
mitigate risk
hemp growers and prosperous will become
aware of and learn about solutions
identified by small working groups
growers and process will create and
document risk management plans
and finally hab growers and processors
will implement risk management plans to
mitigate priority risk leading to
improved economic viability of hemp
enterprises
there are five forms of risk this
includes production marketing financial
legal and human
in the next couple of slides we're going
to give examples of risk that are
associated with this project and then
followed by that we're going to go over
the survey results from new york and
vermont and then
get into the
the solutions that the industry meetings
and one on meetings concluded with the
hemp growers and processors in new york
and vermont
when we talk about marketing risk we're
talking about our available price points
that we can sell our product at
our available markets that we can sell
our product into our hemp or
our value-added products
when it comes down to legal risk
examples of legal risk are our liability
insurance
our property insurance
our contracts that we might have with
our growers and processors
our taxes
and potential environmental risk
financial risks would include
our costs and availability of debt
capital
the ability to meet cash so being able
to
pay our own employees pay our bills
and then our ability to maintain and
grow profitability of the business
when it comes down to human risk our
human risk would consist of having
enough labor to work on our farm having
enough labor to work in our processing
facilities
being able to
uphold to the state and national labor
regulations that are out there
and then also finding enough skilled
labor to be able to work on your farm or
your processing facilities
examples of production risk would be on
your farm the weather
pest
diseases and then in a processing
facility for hemp it would be
the machinery making sure that you have
the correct machinery that
is able to do
the value-added process that you're
doing with the hemp
so for industry participation in this
project we reached out to hemp growers
and processors in new york and vermont
in a couple different formats
in new york and vermont we surveyed the
industry so that the hemp growers and
processes could identify
sources of risk based on the five forms
of risk that
that we're discussing
then in new york we held industry
meetings that included growers and
processors so they could
review the survey results
and then come up with potential
solutions for the industry
and then on the vermont side we held
one-on-one
meetings
with individuals to go over the surveys
results and then
those individuals could come up with
solutions that best
would work for the industry in vermont
so at our new york industry meetings in
our one-on-one meetings one of the big
things that
we made sure that the participants
understood is that
there are a lot of risks that are
associated with the hemp industries
and
although there we we can identify these
risks not everything is going to be
solved in these meetings
we're not going to be able to you know
potentially change
regulations when it comes down to it
but the idea behind these meetings is
find solutions such as
you know
have better contracts for
between growers and processors is one
example
we just want to make sure that you're
aware that when it comes down to the
survey results and the solutions for new
york and vermont the results were
basically the same between both
industries
so we combined
the information when it came down to the
upcoming slides
the marketing risk survey results
growers and hemp processors determined
that there was a lack of available
processing capacity
especially for the fiber
industry market access for independent
producers
uh there's issues in regards to
regulations uncertainty
lack of fda designations and standards
there's been issues in the fda cracking
down
on any and all marketing claims
and then demand has been low for hemp
even when it comes down to perfect tempt
that is grown
the hemp growers and processors that
attended the industry meetings came up
with some solutions for the industry
based on the survey results this
included
more clarity in regulatory markets
basically running smaller batches for
processing
develop cooperatives for small more the
craft grown or artisan grown hemp
if you
they've seen uh if you sell directly
from
to customers there's a lower risk of
dealing with issues with fda claims
and then you know work as an industry to
share more information because in the
past hemp growers and processors have
been very secretive on
what their practices are
the surveys results when it came down to
legal risk
included
issues with contract breaches on
purchases
issues with federal government in
regards to the thc percentage
and then there's also the issue of
customers inserting about legal tracing
amounts of thcs in full spectrum
hemp products
when it came to legal risk solutions
the hemp growers and processors thought
that a monthly newsletter which included
regular updates on what is happening in
the industry would be very helpful
if stronger legal contracts were built
between growers and processors
and
if more education was developed
for customers to learn about full
spectrum products that are available on
the
market
according to the survey results
for financial risk there have been many
issues in regards to
access to banks and services and
insurance that's available
economic development grants and
financing opportunities are not
available
capital is hard to get
capital investment for fiber production
involving large-scale investments up
front to scale to profit
at the industry meeting the hump growers
and processors found that when it came
down to financial risk there are
solutions in order to finance for
growing and for processing of hemp it
just takes a little bit of time you need
to spend some time calling around to
different financial institutions
asking if they will
support your business
and they did see that if you call around
to like smaller banks or institutions
they were more willing to
to work with processors and growers
have growers and processors saw that
when it came down to
issues in the industry for human
and labor
the main risks were there's a shortage
of supply of skilled and unskilled labor
high labor cost
sometimes there's been issues with
inside job thieves and people ruin the
entire crop at the end of the drying
process textile manufacturing would need
more
production avenues for different levels
of processing
and
the hemp industry tends to attract shady
people is what was one of the results so
that's been a mixed bag of characters
when it came to solutions for human and
labor risk issues
the hemp growers and processors felt
that if they could find
veterans that are transitioning into the
industry that would be a wonderful
labor source for them
if they could share labor between
different growers and process implants
and a lot of the hemp growers and
processors that i spoke to on the
vermont side especially
were growing the head but also
processing it
and their advice was to start small and
then slowly grow your business and that
has been
very helpful and worked for these
different have growers and processors
when it came down to production risk
according to survey results
the issues have been in regards to pes
and pathogens remaining poorly
understood
issues with the percentage of thc
the inability to certify commercial
kitchens
the issue of impurities in the soil and
the hemp basically pulling up those
impurities and putting them into your
hemp crop
issues with wind
rain
and dew
so we've got issues with the weather
and then issues with correct industrial
genetics
for
the hemp plant that you're growing based
on the climate and location
solutions for production risk included
researching more on the genetics of hemp
educate
have growers and processors on the
different impurities
that are in the soil that can be
pulled up into the hemp plant
and then also potentially creating a
newsletter that goes out
weekly
bi-weekly monthly especially during the
growing season
to
provide the information to the growers
on what pests and pathogens
are in the environment
after the survey results
industry meetings and one-on-one
meetings with hemp growers and
processors in new york and vermont
it was determined that the priority risk
areas
are marketing
legal and financial
so from there
the focus needs to be on finding
and
creating solutions for the industry so
as we can see from this model we've
defined the problem
we've created understanding of the
situation
the one-on-one consultations and
industry meetings
created a list of solutions where
we've selected the different areas that
we're going to concentrate on for those
solutions in the future
and then moving forward in the next year
we're going to be setting up goals
implementing solutions
and reflecting on the results
our plan for the next year of the
project is we're going to prepare a
report that summarizes the risk and
solutions
that were determined by the hemp growers
and processors in new york and vermont
in specifically to marketing legal and
financial
we plan to continue to work with hemp
growers
one-on-one to identify solutions for the
industry
and then hold one more industry meeting
potentially in vermont and new york to
have identified solutions
and then share the results that we have
from this project at our hemp field days
in new york and vermont
we're really looking for
input from hemp growers and processors
all throughout new york and vermont so
if you want to be part of this project
at all please
reach out to myself for john and we'd be
happy to have
your input in this project
janus yes
can i just mention that uh we do have a
four-page summary report that uh was
provided uh you know for expo purposes
and not sure just how we
how you're gonna circulate those but
there is
there is something available that uh
provides a little greater detail
thank you
thank you john for mentioning that
there is a resource site
yeah there will be a proceedings like
yeah they'll be
when we're all done
okay thank you now
it's time for our
hemp entrepreneur panel
and i'm very
happy to introduce our three panelists
who include tim mcdowell from bristol
extracts located in rochester
hello guys they're all sitting in order
on my screen so that's great brittany
carbone
with her company is tonic cbd she's
located outside of ouigo new york
and max huber
with beacon skiff
so they're each going to present
the story of their business the entry
and development of their products and
potentially different hurdles they faced
or
thoughts for the future so with that um
tim you're first on my screen do you
mind kicking us off let's do it
and we didn't really put something
together last night so
i was a late entry here
so um
so my name is uh tim mcdowell i'm the
ceo of bristol extracts
um
relatively new to the new york hemp
scene
though i have a
long experience with a high thc cannabis
i was fortunate to be right place right
time
in denver and we started a vertical
integrated dispensary processing grow
transferred from black market to medical
market
in colorado
did a lot of r d on product development
then
and then 2014 we expanded that into
adult use in colorado and
became one of the first msos back when
you could be a owner-operated
mso in the cannabis world
we expanded to nevada and illinois in
2015 with our brand of um infused
products to varying uh
levels of success um
we learned some very expensive lessons
then
we were two of us partners never took
outside money and funded it um
got interested in hemp around this time
and we started a genetics program in
colorado really in 2012 2013 trying to
create
a one-to-one strains using some of these
sour tsunami and kanatonic strains
and then honestly quickly realized we
were out of our wheelhouse and started
working with a tissue culture lab and
stabilizing
um some high cbd cannabis genetics i
exited that business uh over covid
took a job with bristol extracts i'm i'm
from pennsylvania so came back to the
east coast
bristol extracts has been in the hemp
business here in new york
for going on four years now as a
cultivator genetics
also creating genetics cultivating
extracting and uh
product manufacturing
um so we're located the facility is
located in bristol valley outside
canandaigua i can see from where i'm
sitting the uh ski resort here so it's a
beautiful place to to work
we have about a 20 000 square foot um
gmp certified facility we just passed
our uh renewal audit last tuesday 97
so we're pretty stoked about that
um and we have 30 acres around here um
with some good soil that we've planted
on here in addition to some off-site
fields as well in the past the facility
is pretty uh amazing it's geothermal
heated and cooled it's very green
building green roofs
all of our toilet water is rain water we
have about 25 000 gallons cistern under
under the ground outback to catch water
and then we have a um a creek and a pond
a
pond that we built for the geothermal
system on site
so we
you can see our warehouse there that
picture's a little outdated
so we'll bring in uh plant material uh
process pre-process it we do
mostly ethanol extraction we've started
to dabble we have a pretty
amazing solvent-less system in-house now
um
that we're doing some r d on but our
ethanol has been the bread butter for
the past few years
it's a large system that we can process
up to about 3 000 pounds a day so that
comes with its own challenges uh and
then we have the post-processing tech on
the back side of that
which is a lot of it's run through a
white film distillation we do micro nano
particlization water solubility although
what's becoming quickly the standard in
the business and then we have our
quality control systems in-house and
that is hplc testing our mrp system um
which is our software to kind of monitor
all of our manufacturing and so
we're pretty uh
tech focused here we're we've done a lot
of r d for uh products outside of our
company as well as as branded uh
products and just developing ip honestly
in the hemp space as uh
the business
prior to me coming on kind of pivoted
from a toll processing grower just
processing crude oil
into its own you know more vertical um
without the retail
end product business
what's the next question here how do we
go about deciding our products so
you know we watch for trends and
cannabis consumer packaged goods
nutraceutical
as we all know hemp cannabinoids have
been commoditized relatively quickly
and thc is is on the same on the same
path
and so i think that we can see
you know there are differences between
the cannabinoids of what the end product
use is
um
we have a system of focus groups that we
use both uh
more in person now actually but a lot of
online as we're expanding into some
international sales we get into these
different um
communities and just different needs and
different wants for what the products
are so it's a lot a large learning curve
for us to learn
what people want
can we
fulfill it um is it within our
wheelhouse um and if it's not sometimes
we'll do that r d and then you know it's
simply uh well nothing none of it's
simple but
sell or license that into a market that
then is off of our manufacturing hands
because we are not co-packing um
for anybody else and we are not having
any of our products go back
i know we're behind so i'll keep talking
quick here i think industry improvements
i'm taking my expertise from the
cannabis world into in
the marijuana world really i know it's
all cannabis but into the hemp world
educate educate educate and and the more
that we can educate
uh
the end consumer the um the retailer the
regulators um whoever it is
as an industry we need to have a
consistent
voice
um
you know if if mac and his company over
there are doing great and and and we at
bristol mess up something in our
products it kind of muddies the waters
for hemp as a whole you know and so
good processors and and good uh
businesses need to really carry the
torch um
i think the the no green rush mentality
is huge i think we're starting to see
that again
with hemp farmers thinking that
that the
provisional rule here in new york is
going to kind of save them uh where it
may be a pitfall right back into where
they were two years ago and so uh
build a long-term business strategy um
the price of cannabinoids through hemp
in
in marijuana high thc is continuing to
go down and it will continue to go down
if you look at michigan the report that
just came out prices are bonding out
there
back to carrying the torch poor quality
over hyped businesses there's snake oil
salesmen all through the hemp world
don't be them call them out demand you
know cfa's if you're making label claims
um customers and in retail need to to
have them uh backed up
um
i i gotta i gotta fit a hunter thompson
quote in here somewhere there's no such
thing as paranoia your worst fears can
come true at any moment
that is so true in crazy businesses such
as him um
you got to take control of the situation
as best as you can get involved stay
involved through organizations start
organizations join them
just get involved get involved with
people that disagree with you
um talk it out be transparent we're very
transparent at bristol anyone's welcome
to come see the facility come see what
we do
[Music]
we're continuing to learn uh next steps
for us as a company uh
entering into the adult use provisional
licenses if we're so lucky to uh get one
since we qualify um but also on the hemp
side to continue to our hemp cbd
products like i had mentioned before
expand into hopefully some international
sales
and just continue to work on the tech
and and build a good long business
and be members of the community so thank
you for the invite i i learned i was
going to be involved in this last night
so i'm happy to come and talk
and we really appreciate that
flexibility tim thank oh thank you of
course thank you
it's a great presentation i think we'll
hold questions for now and try to get
through our other two panelists
so if you have a burning question make a
quick note to yourself so we can get to
it after
so thank you for having me last minute
edition as well but always happy to uh
help out with cornell and the
cooperative extension and all the
fantastic work that um guys do for the
hemp industry in new york so very happy
to be here um i'm brittany carbone i'm
the founder and ceo of tonic cbd also
the co-founder of treccola farms and
barto labs
together we form a craft boutique
vertically integrated hemp cbd operation
that spans across new york and
pennsylvania
i'm also a board member of the new york
cannabis growers and process association
and the chair of the association
sustainability committee
so that's really um you know a big part
of our business model the sustainability
and really taking a much smaller
boutique approach than you know what
might have seen in
tim's facility um you know we're not
doing 3000 pounds a day we're doing
about 10 000 pounds a year of capacity
um really focusing on uh you know strain
specific i'm sorry my dog's going a
little crazy right now excuse me
it's quiet uh but
get into that a little bit more so this
is our you know supply chain right here
it's all starts at tricola farms
that material goes to barto labs we do
you know single origin
extracts meaning that everything that we
process
comes from chichola farms unless we are
you know entering into a contract uh
toll processing for other small farmers
in the area um it is a service that we
you know did not plan on offering at
first but because the
uh you have to be adaptable in the hemp
market right you need to be able to
pivot on uh some very short notice and
be able to you know be open to
opportunity wherever it presents itself
so um really
like the way that we like to you know
stay adaptable while staying true to our
business model and our vision of really
um like small scale craft sustainable uh
practices is by you know making sure
that we're
anyway that we're expanding or pivoting
away from that original business model
is still in line with those values so
like i said we're working with very
small-scale farmers who are looking to
get their material processed be able to
have a better path to market a more
profitable path to market than just
selling biomass because that is not a
path to market right now as we all as we
all know um even you know just getting
extracts back is not really great so you
know farmers want to be able to sell
their own product right like that's the
story that that farmers can really
leverage when they're when they're
creating a brand right because they're
not going to have the huge marketing
budgets they're not going to have that
kind of
fuel behind them but what they can have
is a story a story of how this product
was grown how it was handled what's the
meaning behind it so we wanted to offer
that to farms
to be able to make their own products
with their material and tell that story
but then also be able to take
you know brands especially in indie and
minority-owned brands in the beauty and
wellness space
be able to allow them to leverage the
trekola farm story so that's yeah we'll
get into that a little bit more but
that's kind of the the model that we're
creating here is really taking very
intentional um sustainably grown
material that very high quality
processing it in a very again
intentional and uh you know craft
artisanal kind of uh kind of way making
innovative products that are going to be
competitive even in the most crowded
market and then funneling those extracts
and those products either into the tonic
brand or into the brand uh that barto
that our lab fuels
so chocola farms is uh one of the first
privately licensed hemp farms in new
york state uh licensed back in 2017.
i should say privately licensed to grow
cannabinoids um
we are located in berkshire new york so
right between um ithaca and binghamton
which is you know a great great area to
be nestled in between family owned and
operated we've had our this property
since 2004. my husband and i actually
got married i guess my husband in this
picture right here and we got married on
the farm 2015 we started to spend a lot
more time up there and then when i
created
the tonic product line which i've
created out of my own uh my own need to
try to find a natural way to manage my
anxiety and depression i was working as
a personal trainer at the time uh
certified nutrition and health coach and
uh just looking for these natural
alternatives something that could help
me like cannabis always did but uh was
more work day friendly and that's really
when i discovered cbd of late 2016 and
by early 2017 i was combining cbd with
adaptogens superfoods and these other
herbs to really create a more
synergistic and effective experience and
these products changed my life i started
to change uh share them with my clients
my clients were getting the same kind of
results and that's when i really started
to be like wow this could actually be a
business like it was you know early 2017
like right you know perfect timing to
enter the
cbd industry you know before before it
really exploded
but the problem being that i was having
a really difficult time sourcing uh
consistently high quality material um so
that was why we were like while we have
all this property upstate we're spending
more time up there anyway we decided to
leave our full-time jobs on long island
and move full-time up to the farm with
my parents uh with my uncle and my
father-in-law at the time we were just
all a big happy family growing hemp for
the first year and uh yeah we've
definitely learned a lot we got our hemp
stolen from us from one of these bad
actors that you were talking about
earlier it's been an absolutely wild
ride so the one year that we were in the
hemp industry where pharma was actually
profitable we got our prop stolen from
us uh we were able to retain some of it
you know but this is this is the reality
of the hemp and cannabis industry right
like tim was saying like you can't just
go after this for the money because
you're gonna get your heart broken real
quick right you gotta be able to
to uh stay in there and you know really
have some passion that drives you and
some you know really something that's
going to um to ground you in the madness
so to speak but i like i said we're kind
of just you know stayed um stayed true
to the vision we are very brand focused
very much um you know
uh focus on developing brands through
all part of the supply chain to be able
to add value um like bi-directional
value through the supply chain right um
so that's really
a big part of how we are able to also
drive value into the farm through
agrotourism that's a big part of what we
offer during the summer is you know farm
tours farm visits educate people about
the importance of sustainable craft
cultivation in cannabis um about kind of
you know taking care of the land about
appreciating where your cannabis
products come from where your food
products come from right and it's a lot
of bringing people up from the city um
who don't usually have this experience
to you know get a more kind of hands-on
uh experience on the on these farms and
uh be able to connect to the source of
their healing like this so this is
that's been a really great uh
kind of addition to our business model
especially on the farm side where you
know the profits aren't as easy to come
by um and then we have bordeaux labs
like i said uh state state-of-the-art
excuse me boutique scout
manufacturing and uh processing facility
in sayer pennsylvania we're just over
the new york border into pennsylvania uh
we are cgmp compliant just waiting on
our uh on our audit um coming in the
next couple of months so everybody wish
us luck on that and uh we are making
custom formulations and white label
products like i said both for um you
know fueling the tonic brand which is a
you know our flagship in-house brand as
well as you know about 30 other um 30
other brands in the wellness and beauty
space um which i'm very proud to say
that 90 of those brands are minority
owned and that's really what our focus
is is um empowering and uplifting and
democratizing ownership across the space
and creating a launch pad for these
brands to really create innovative
products and not just have to
be forced to kind of just white label to
have a pathway to ownership to actually
be able to have ip and be able to you
know create something that's innovative
and that can compete in a very crowded
and very um you know kind of monotonous
industry as yeah you walk into a cvd
store and it's a lot of the same exact
products with different labels on it
right and that's exactly what we want to
try to avoid
all right and then uh finally tonic our
finished product line uh you know do
direct to consumer and uh retail
distribution
focusing on uh innovative herbal
tincture blends like i was saying before
when i started to really combine
cbd with all these other um adaptogens
and superfoods is when i really started
for myself to feel like this is actually
you know life-changing results that i
was feeling right where cbd was able to
get me most of the way adaptogens were
able to get me most of the way combining
the two in a very you know mindful way
was able to get me the results that i
was really looking for and that's kind
of been the um
the the thought process and pattern that
has kind of taken shape with the rest of
the product line some products you know
we keep a lot more simple but again with
you know a very um targeted goal in mind
when we're talking about you know what
do we want what uh results do we want
the products to to elicit each product
is designed to you know really target
specific needs states um much more
consistently because yeah that's the
great and you know tricky thing about
cbd is that it can do so much but it can
uh lead to very varied results right so
we kind of take the guesswork and the
variability out of that by um using the
cbd with all these other synergistic
ingredients so
we also are distributing uh starting to
distribute other brands who source from
chicola farms and barto labs so see
these chocolate bars that are in this
photo here um that is floor de maria
which is a brand that we've been working
with to uh supply the cbd for since the
very beginning and uh they are they are
just add up really something different
to our product line uh really artisanal
um
delicious cbd infused chocolates we're
also you know starting to just bring in
other brands that uh that manufacture
through bardo and chocolate farms into
the mix and really telling the story
again more so of uh you know lifting up
the value of craft and you know and
minority-owned uh products as a whole as
you know kind of firm believer that the
ships all rise with the tide so we're
trying to really
speak to the the value of the sector of
the industry as a whole and uplift
conscious consumerism in a much broader
way than just trying to focus on one
brand in particular um we believe that
truly democratizing the space means and
you know bringing the most healing to
the most people truly means
to reach into new audiences leverage new
audiences and speak to people that maybe
we don't know how to um that we wouldn't
reach ourselves right to be able to
expand that opportunity into the market
but then also expand the opportunity and
ownership um and really create
a much more um diverse marketplace so uh
we have a very strong new york um market
presence you know we've done a lot to
you know really kind of um
build up our market in new york which
makes us you know very excited moving
forward into the uh adult use market
we do have a strong set of brands to go
forward with and you know be able to um
really fuel with tricola farms thc
flower like we have been with the cbd on
the cbd side so like i was saying before
um you know it's continue to see it
being very important to drive value
through the supply chain in both
directions meaning that you know the um
the value of chocola farms and the
quality that we stand by the agritourism
all these things that we do through
triple farms drives value to the brands
that your cola farms fuels and then the
brand recognition from tonic and the
brands on the on the front end on the
retail side the reputation that they
have in the marketplace the brand
recognition that drives value into you
know the other parts of the supply chain
as well so definitely um you know
finding ways to optimize the synergy
going forward to
enter into more brand licensing
agreements through the thc market are
all really opportunities that are
definitely on top of mind right now and
just really figuring out how to manage
all of it you know as a very small
business with limited capital and a
limited team behind us it's
every day is a new adventure but
love what we do and you know we're very
very passionate about helping people not
only um heal through our products but
helping people to you know actually gain
ownership and you know have more
opportunity in this industry support our
community support education and you know
do all we can to um to educate about the
importance of conscious consumerism
within the cannabis space
wow brittany thank you that was a really
excellent presentation i feel like you
were like
forced to rush through it but that was
uh
wanted to get it all in you know yeah no
thank you and it's nice to have a range
of business sizes and uh you know
directions here so i really appreciate
that
and the fact that you could um join us
with kind of late notice
so our third panelist this morning is
mac huber
my name is mack huber i'm cfo of beacon
skiff and 1911 established and i'm also
our general manager of our cannabis
division which we're calling beacon
skiff research
for those of you who don't know beacon
skiff
we're just outside of syracuse for 111
year old
family owned apple orchard
about a thousand acre apple orchard
and really what we specialize in is
vertical integration we grow apples here
we press them
we ferment them into our hard cider and
our spirits and then we serve them at
our tasting rooms on site here
so
you know
our goals i guess we actually have three
different beverage facilities on site
here we have our
canning and bottling line we have our
natural drinks uh facility and a
distillery on site
so
while we are an apple orchard at heart
really were a
premium beverage maker that's how we
look at ourselves and
we wanted to take the same seed to sip
approach that we have with apples and
our hard cider and apply that to hemp so
we
initially got into uh were interested in
the hemp industry
to long-term make cannabis-infused
beverages so cbd infused beverages
and we wanted to take that same vertical
integration model from apples and apply
it to him so growing the hemp here
growing the organic hemp
extracting it with
ethanol that we make at our distillery
and then infusing it into beverages that
we can here on site
we looked at cannabinoids similarly to
the other active ingredients of
beverages that we work with right now so
obviously ethanol aka
alcohol
and also caffeine so we do a lot of cold
brew coffee and we looked at you know
cannabinoids cbd as just another active
ingredient that we could work with
and
most people probably on this call are
very familiar with the first two
active ingredients ethanol and caffeine
and most are used to consuming that in a
beverage form and we thought
cannabinoids shouldn't be any different
so
you know we really set out to
make a
compliant uh
organic cbd infused beverages and we
actually a year ago came out
um with i'm kind of forgetting the slide
here
so our first
cbd beverage now
this was a challenge and that
i'm sure tim and brittany know
new york only allowed cbd products to be
made as a dietary supplement in a
dietary supplement facility so this was
one of the regulation challenges that we
had so
we went through a whole dietary
supplement audit on our canning facility
it was already a really high food safety
sqf audited facility but now it's also a
dietary supplement facility so that's
how we were able to make a compliant
beverage cbd beverage in new york
and be able to ensure retailers in new
york that they could keep this on shelf
you know
one thing that we really wanted to
separate ourselves from the other cbd
beverages out there was you know this
certified organic today we're the only
ones in the country i think with that
logo on our cans
you know that starts again with growing
the organic hemp on site the ethanol
that we produce is certified organic our
extraction facility
uh certified organic and
ultimately the goal was to make organic
products so
kind of jumping to
our extraction facility we call the hemp
house
you know we went with an ethanol
extraction mainly again because we're
used to working with ethanol at our
distillery
so we
are kind of in between tim and brittany
in terms of volume uh we kind of
aim for around 500 pounds a day volume
we focus a lot on organic extraction so
organic ethanol
and you can see in a picture here this
is just the uh
on the on the right side here this is
our delta cup extractor
and then
on the next slide you'll see our
distillation skid so we like to take um
we'd like to extract to crude and then
further refine into a distillate
we just for our products we like to use
just a distillate as the raw ingredients
for us it's just a more consistent clean
ingredient
with you know there's definitely been
challenges in new york with
beverages um so while we were uh
figuring out the
canning facility uh challenges we
decided to diversify our product lineup
and
offer tinctures uh gummies balms
we've since come out with drink mixes
lotions
and so we really wanted to offer our
customers
different form factors to fit their
everyday you know needs
our extraction facility you know so it's
cgmp
certified organic
kosher and we also do a lot of
co-packing so beacon skips
all of our
facilities about half of the capacity is
for our own brands and then half the
capacity is for coat packing
so we took that same model applied it to
our hemp house and we co-packed for a
good number of local new york brands
um and private label some as well
um what was the other questions
oh really when we're deciding on making
products um
you know one thing that
we really focus on is obviously making
really high quality products but also at
a price that's affordable to our
consumers
and beverages is a great example right
we sell our individual cans for 250.
each can has 20 milligrams of cbd so
it's a great
entry
product for
the curious customer right they don't
have to go out and spend
the amount of dollars on a tincture or
one of our bombs they can try one of our
seltzers
um
so that's you know was our goal with our
drinks and our tinctures we'd like to be
you know a relatively uh
a price point that works for most
consumers
um
and really
more recently with the news obviously
with new york going adult use
all the products that we're making
now we will hopefully be able to
transition over to thc so
obviously drinks big one
tinctures bombs that kind of stuff
let's see
so i talked about some of the hurdles
obviously beverages is definitely a
hurdle doing the dietary supplement
we've
since then
the office of cannabis management
has actually changed the regs so
cbd can now be
sold marketed as a nutritional label
product so no longer a supplement panel
but a nutritional panel
um
but at least this gives us the
flexibility because actually we sell our
cbd seltzers
out of state and some states only allow
cbd as a dietary supplement some
don't care and will allow as a
nutritional label or a supplement label
so these are it gives us the versatility
more recently though with the hemp
extract regs there was language in there
that
was going to prevent
cold chain cbd products or hemp based
products
you know we uh
produce a little bit of cbd cold brew we
actually do a lot of cold brew coffee
here so we're familiar with it and we
wanted to infuse it with some of our cbd
as well
we worked with the regulators to help
educate them on you know
labels having all the correct expiration
dates so consumers won't get confused
about
product going bad after i don't know
three months or whatnot
and also you know
it's very clear on the label that this
product needs to be refrigerated so
we worked closely with the ocm to get
that language uh removed
and so hopefully we can start making
some more cbd cold brew
in the near future
looking ahead uh really we're focusing
on
beverages that's kind of what we know
and we'll be looking to build a new thc
drink facility
to really just focus on infusing
um
either our seltzers more coffee or
potentially a fresh cider with some thc
so
that's kind of our
long view right now um
yeah and in terms of uh
industry improvements i'm gonna
piggyback off what tim said i think it
was perfect you know educate educate
educate
um
and really i think what new york did
with their
hemp regulations from a labeling
standpoint from consumer safety
it was spot on so hopefully we see other
states adopt this
so that customers all across the country
can feel confident when they're buying
something
you know what they're intaking is the
actual marketed potency and there's no
heavy metals or pesticides so i think
again what new york did was uh was
amazing and i hope other states follow
suit
so
i'll stop there janice because i know
we're tight
on time
thank you very much mac
um thank you very much to all the
panelists that was a nice
range of business size and product
development
i hope our uh viewers found that
interesting
mary do we have time to allow a question
or two yeah actually i have one so i'm
going to take it um
brittany
you mentioned that your first profitable
crop was stolen so without naming names
because i think it was one way and not
the other
you sold it but never got a check not
you woke up one morning and it was just
missing
exactly yeah i'll name names john flynn
if anybody ever sees him punch him in
the face but uh
[Laughter]
no but honestly he he we weren't the
only farmers that he hit it was a group
of us that went into a group deal with
them um you know yeah
i'm bringing that back to john's
conversation and i've done some you know
stuff with contracts and whatnot and so
yeah i'm and i you know tim's on we've
trying to get again markets to have a
bonding so that you know to encourage
producers to
only sell to bonded buyers so that there
is recourse uh in the vegetable industry
of fruit and vegetable industries we
have this
so um trying to build that up but of
course sellers
all of you that grow
have to stick to that
if it's gonna work and it's gonna be a
thing
then all the sellers have to only sell
to bonded because all it takes is one
guy who goes around and doesn't get the
bonding but can get product and that's
not worth anything anymore and it's not
really a good system so i just want to
put that out there because there are a
lot of
shenanigans
that i was
shocked by
and having worked with special producers
for many many years and you know large
sales you know not not really cash
business but that kind of handshakey
kind of stuff like here's my stuff and
you'll send me a check in two weeks
never having it been that bad before
so
yeah they can get definitely tricky and
it's definitely something uh you know
now with
i thcm tim you said it perfectly before
that you know we don't want to end up in
the same position that we were in a few
years ago with hemp now with you know
the launch of these conditional licenses
where people are getting a little bit uh
over their skis a little bit you know
what i mean and really making sure that
we're doing this responsibly and i do
think that that really a big part of
that becomes uh kind of joining together
because this is you know we are uh you
know kind of need to
join forces as hemp growers entering
this this into this new market and set
the standards also for price points and
you know what we're going to sell for
and what we want to hold uh you know
kind of
what kind of terms we want to see and
how do we um compete with these larger
um you know out-of-state operators that
are going to be coming in the ros that
are already here and how do we you know
make sure that we're creating a
marketplace that is fair kind of you
know for farmers in general
creating opportunities and supporting
each other rather than you know creating
a race to the bottom
well said well said thank you brandon
yes good afternoon
thank you for having me here to speak
about the new york state amateur
licensed new program department of
agriculture and markets
uh a short presentation and then i'll be
able to take questions at the end
that should be on there but not
everybody is exactly
up front uh the 2018 federal farm bill
required that the new york state
industrial have research pilot program
program under which may have been
licensed for the past several years that
had to expire on january 1st 2022 this
was something that had to occur in all
states though all those pilot programs
expired at the beginning of this year
and the farm bill also provided that
states wishing to administer a have
licensing program
had to have a plan approved by the usda
in order to be able to do that new york
state submitted
our
program plan to the usda last year and
it was approved in november
if you want to take a look at that you
can go on the usda webpage
just usda hemp program and you'll be
able to find
our program and that of all the other
states that have
been approved
so some new requirements in 2022 now
that the pilot program has gone away and
we're operating under a
under a new program all previously
licensed growers
their license those licenses have
expired so you will need to apply to the
new program and get a new license
there's also a
hemp seed seller license required this
year if you're interested in selling
hemp siege you would need to apply for
that license that's a that's a new thing
this year we do have program guidance
document on our
on our website
you can
go there and it has a lot of information
about the program and some frequently
asked questions
we have also adopted regulations this
year which is new in the past we
operated under that research partner
agreement that any of you were growers
in the pilot program are familiar with
it was the contract that you signed me
between you and the state and pretty
much was the way we regulated the
program
the new regs are available on our
website right on the home page you
scroll all the way down to law and
regulations and it's the part 159 ranks
that you would want to
look at we're hoping that having
regulations in place will add
some clarity and certainty to uh
to the growers in the program and to us
to be honest with you
the
fbi check has to be no more than 60 days
old so if you have an old
fbi check that you have done in the past
for some other reason that's not going
to cut it for this
purpose it has to be no more than 60
days old this is a federal requirement
and we have to abide by that
you can go to many post offices or law
enforcement offices and they can
do some fingerprinting for you and you
submit them electronically to the fbi
and they are turning them around really
quickly if you submit electronically if
however you submit them hard copy it
i've heard it's several weeks now
um
also new total thc of not more than
point three percent is a standard for
compliance a total thc
is is the standard we have to go by now
that is a federal requirement so we
don't have any
any wiggle room there
uh also new
the department will not be the primary
sampler or tester of hemp crops this
year
the new federal requirements uh
are such that all hemp lots all fields
all greenhouses will have to be sampled
and we just would not be able to to meet
that sampling responsibility so we are
going into a
system where we will be training uh
private individuals interested in being
certified sampling agents and they will
be the ones that are hired by the
growers the growers will be responsible
for the cost of the sampling and testing
the private sampling agent will come out
take your samples and mail them to the
lab of your choice
we have a list of labs on our website
that you can you can use for your your
testing
growers cannot sample their own crop and
they also cannot be sampling agents this
is also dictated by the federal law so
you will need to hire a private sampling
agent
also new this year but perhaps familiar
to those of you who
have farmed other crops in the past is
registering your growing locations with
your local usda farm service agency
office
that needs to be done within 10 days
after planting and then we will get the
information the fsa will send
information to us they'll send it to the
usda and usda in turn is going to notify
the
u.s drug enforcement agency of all the
growing locations for hemp in the
country
so applying for a license
looks a lot uh very similar to
to what you've done in the past with a
few
changes as i mentioned you also have to
submit the fbi background check
you do not have to have a research plan
in place anymore this is no longer a
research pilot program this is full-on
commercialization so we've done away
with the requirement for the research
plan
and we don't require that you submit a
marketing plan with us we still do
require you give us your name address
and phone number
uh your ein if you have one if you're a
sole proprietor you don't necessarily
have to have one of those
you'll need to provide us with the uh
the address
and gps coordinates for your growing
locations along with a map or aerial
photo of the locations
depicting where the buildings and
structures and access points are
i'm going to say a word here about the
gps coordinates this is
far and away
the thing that holds up most uh the
applications that don't make it through
on their first attempt people just do
not get the gps coordinates right
so wait the way to do it the best way
that i found
go on google maps
you put in your the address of your
growing location
when the map pops up there's going to be
a little satellite photo aerial photo
thumbnail
picture you click on that and then zoom
in a bit and place your cursor either in
the center of the field you're going to
grow on or over the building you're
going to use
and right click and the gps coordinates
will pop up in a box
people that are trying to use their
phones or other um programs to find gps
are
they're coming way off the mark i had
one the other day that was in the
atlantic ocean and so
try to go on
i urge you strongly to use google maps
to find the
gps coordinates
we'll still need to know where you're
getting your seed from what varieties
you're going to get
and also what your aerial focus will be
whether you're going growing for fiber
grain or cbd
also there's a line on the application
to let us know if you were in the
program in the past what your what your
number was
your registration number and once again
it's a non-refundable 500 application
fee
and the license is good for
three years
just a
few examples of reasons that
applications get denied if the
application isn't right or isn't
complete i can't approve that
if you've had a recent drug related
felony just drug related felonies other
felonies don't matter
within 10 years that would be a
disqualifying feature that is a federal
requirement
failing to provide us with a background
check with the application it's going to
get denied
if you're trying to register a location
that someone else already has registered
you we're not allowing that to happen
we can't have two different growers in
the same field
um if if
the sample from that field was hot you'd
have to destroy the whole field
so
that just doesn't work out
if you're going to if you're proposing
to grow in an area that is zoned
residential
or if you're proposing to grow inside a
residence or an attached garage that
is not approvable
failure to sign your application failure
to submit the application fee and there
are a couple other reasons that people's
applications have been denied
other considerations
know where you're going to sell your
hemp before you plant
every fall we get calls i planted to him
now what do i do with it
and that's not a good situation to be in
so really know what you're going to do
know what your market is before you plan
to hemp and
and it'll be a
much more pleasant experience
know your zoning zoning is a local issue
in new york state so know what zoning
regulations are in place in the area in
which you're proposing to grow
and once again you can't grow in a house
or an attached garage
growers will be will be routinely
inspected at least once per the
three-year licensing cycle but we
reserve the right to inspect more
frequently if that's warranted
and uh once again no um
know the characteristics of the
varieties you're going to plant if they
have a tendency to go hot make sure you
stay on top of sampling throughout the
growing season so that you don't end up
in a situation where you're going to
have to destroy your crop in the fall
once again thc is based total thc
is the standard now
so
no more than 0.3 total thc
now back to the certified sampling
agents uh just for a minute i'll explain
some of that program um
we do have a training module that's
available and a brief exam that you
would take if you're interested in being
a sampling agent
you would need to have a valid driver's
license be 21 years of age have a
background check done
just like the growers do
then you would determine you know which
counties in the state you'd want to
serve what your service area will be
you're going to be your own boss so
you'll be able to
to make that determination for yourself
you'll set your own price for sampling
and mailing the samples to the growers
chosen lab we recommend that you have
liability insurance highly recommend
that and
if this sounds like something that you
are interested in or if you know someone
that may be interested in
in becoming an assembly agent please
contact chuck schmidt at the department
of agriculture and markets he is
coordinating the sampling agent program
you can be reached at 518-807-7194
so i've come to the end of my
presentation and i'm going to take some
questions here but before i start taking
questions i need to let everyone know
that any questions regarding growing
adult use marijuana medical marijuana
marijuana dispensaries
cbd processing the sale of cbd products
or raw hemp flour smokables should be
addressed to the office of cannabis
management that's the agency that's
responsible for all things marijuana and
all things cbd other than cbd hemp
growing
so there here is their contact
information if you don't have an
opportunity to write this all down you
can google new york state ocm and you
will get to their web page
tim i don't know if you wanna
share because that was information no
sure um
you know
i'm all set for questions now i guess if
anybody has any i know we're over time
you're sorry
that's not that's my bad for that it's
probably not
that's probably something i did wrong
i'll take it though okay
so i have a couple of questions
um
are you restricting varieties that
people can grow
we don't we don't restrict varieties
we
urge people to
keep an eye on on the varieties that
that tend to go hot but right now we do
not have a list of restricted varieties
that may happen in the future
[Music]
we have to do a little more data
collection on varieties wow yeah
and the other one is um how's it going
with sampling agents have you talked to
chuck are there some is this going to be
a problem this year people finding
sampling agents
like applied we we certainly hope it's
not going to be a problem we uh
we do have some people that are have
expressed an interest and are
in the process of
getting into the system um and we hope
that as the season
as it gets warmer and people start
thinking more about being outdoors and
growing things that that'll
um
more people will come into the program
so our question came up in the chat is
there a price cap on sampling costs
uh we will not be dictating the price
okay
so yeah i talked to chuck a little bit
and it was like it's like they're going
to be private consultants and it's just
a matter of competition
one guy's charging 200 bucks and the
other guy's charging 400 bucks and
they'll both do your area that's how
it's going to work right yep yeah
i do there's a message here that heather
sent to me uh so maybe i can address
this
um
those who want to home grow under the
mrta provisions when allowed
will those who want to home grow under
the rta provisions when allowed need to
obtain a hemp license if they want to
grow high cbd plants
that's interesting uh you will need if
you're growing hemp you need a license
from us
you can
we're in a we're in a weird situation
here we are running a heavily regulated
hemp program
because we are following federal law and
all the federal requirements
the marijuana side of things the it's
federally illegal but the state has
chosen to to allow growing of marijuana
in the state so
those two things are very very separate
so if you're going to grow hemp you're
you've really you've got to have the
license from us
that's interesting that's kind of a
strange setup
following up on that question
if i want to grow
hem
in my house for my own consumption
do i need a license how many plants can
i grow
you can't grow hemp in your house
or in a residential setting period um
so that that would negate that um
if you wanted you we don't have a
restriction on or the number of plants
you can grow
however you would have to you couldn't
be doing it in a residential setting and
you know in an area zone residential or
within a home
i'm just checking the list if there's
any more uh
i don't see any more questions
but tim you're going to stick around in
case there's a little back and forth
between patrick or something comes up
after patrick presents right because the
two of you are so hand in hand sure yep
okay wouldn't miss it
so i'm going to introduce
patrick mcgee he's with the
office of cannabis management prior it
was the um department of health
because as many of you know you know
marijuana medical marijuana was in
department of health hemp was in ag
markets and now this office of cannabis
management will take on
medical marijuana recreational marijuana
and cbd processing and set distribution
and sales but not the growing portion
because the growing portion is still
hemp that sticks with
ag markets so if that doesn't have
everybody confused yet it'll just um
so we're gonna uh let patrick go patrick
do you want me to play are you ready to
share screen
because you have permission according to
kim you've been given permission to
share screen and you can
just go ahead and
sure i can give it a go sorry one sec
hi my name is patrick and i'm the first
deputy director at the office of
cannabis management
i'm really excited to be here thank you
very quiet we're putting on this
opportunity
hopefully we can uh be doing something
like this soon in person as it's been a
couple years um but nonetheless uh very
excited to be here today and be able to
provide an update on the uh
hemp program in new york state
before i uh kind of dive into that i
thought i'd just provide a brief
background of myself
uh i've been working on the cannabis
file for the past four to five years in
new york state government
i started at the department of taxation
and finance looking at a lot of the
projections and models to see you know
how much tax revenue could new york
state bring in if we did legalize
i then ended up spending a couple years
in the governor's office
working on the legislation that uh later
would become the marijuana regulation
and taxation act
um and then i went over to the
department of health where i had an
opportunity to be part of a team that
helped stand up the cannabinoid hemp
program and work on the medical cannabis
and then uh after the mrta did pass
in march of uh 2021
uh everyone who was working
at the department of health's medical
cannabis program i actually transitioned
over to the the new office of cannabis
management and uh working on
all three cannabis programs in new york
state at large the canada hemp program
the adult use program and the medical
cannabis program so it's been a really
exciting opportunity to be able to
participate in standing up a new agency
in new york state government
i finally think we're at that point
where you know a lot of the
administrative stuff we have the
foundation laid in terms of you know
finding office space buying furniture
hiring
and so now we're really starting to
focus on the policy development which is
the exciting part of the work
and um i'm hoping we'll be able to share
a number of updates in the coming months
so please you know continue to follow
the ocm website and i'm sure there'll be
more information to come
so here's the outline for what i want to
talk about today
um first just provide a brief overview
of the cannabinoid hemp program so we're
all on the same page
then we'll provide some programmatic
updates uh the first one here i think
you maybe have seen in the news recently
uh just last week governor kathy hulkel
signed legislation authorizing the
office of cannabis management to
conditionally license
previous
hemp growers and processors in new york
state to junk start the adult use market
and then we also have some proposed
regulations that are out for public
comment right now that i can provide an
overview for
then i'll provide an update on our
application process going over some of
the different license types and how to
apply for canada temp license
and then uh just do a brief kind of
timeline next steps and we'll have be
sure to leave time for um some questions
and answers
so a brief legislative background on the
cannabinoid hemp program
uh
officially started from a bill which
passed in
2019 and was later chaptered in 2020
that split the regulatory framework
of which agency has control over
different aspects of hemp uh depending
on what it's being sold for
so the cultivation of hemp remained
under the purview of the department of
agriculture and markets
and then the processing manufacturing
and retail sale of cannabinoid had moved
over to the department of health in the
medical marijuana program
now uh the reasoning for putting it into
the medical marijuana program is because
there is just so much overlap as it
relates to the processing manufacturing
of cannabinoid hemp products and the
processing and manufacturing of cannabis
products
after all it's all the same plants and
the only real difference between
hemp and cannabis is the level of thc
content
so what is cannabinoid happening
is defined as any product that is used
for its cannabinoid content
like cbd for human consumption or
topical application
we're not talking about
end products or products derived from
hemp that are
using the seeds or fiber or hemp cream
or anything like that that does not fall
under the preview of the cannabinoid
type program really only looking for
things that people are putting in their
bodies or on their skin
for their cannabinoid content
additionally the program was very
conscious to use the word cannabinoid
rather than just calling it cbd
while cbd is the most popular products
you see on the market today
many of the products out there are
starting to highlight the minor
cannabinoids or terpenes in these uh
cannabinoid or cbd products and we
expect that trend to continue in the
future as anyone who's been following
this topic you can see as it relates to
delta 8 or cbg or cbn products
so it was consciously chosen to make the
canada pep program a little broader than
just the cbd program
so what are the objectives of the
cannabinoid hep program
the naming hemp program is designed to
comprehensively regulate cannabinoid
hemp products in new york state by
providing clear rules for what is
allowed and what is not allowed
one of the biggest problems uh or issues
with the with hemp right now
is that it exists in a bit of a gray
area where the 2018 farm bill
legal era removed hemp from the
controlled substance act and
authorized the usda to create
regulations governing cultivation
meanwhile you had all these
state department of ag
research programs authorizing people to
uh grow hemp and develop products from
it
and as cbd and other cannabis
became more popular
more and more have farmers and
processors starting focusing on uh cbt
products and cannabinoid hemp products
immediately after the 2018 farm building
passed the fda came out with a statement
and basically said
you know i know there's a lot of
interest in the cbd uh cannabinoid out
there however um we'd like to remind
everyone that because of this drug
exclusion rule that basically says any
ingredient that is an active ingredient
in a pharmaceutically approved product
is not allowed to be added to food or
beverage products
so uh cbd is part of a pharmaceutically
approved drug called epidialex and
because of that the fda has taken the
position that uh cbd cannot be added to
normal food or beverage products or in
commerce or they have regulatory
jurisdiction over this
this has created a problem because
obviously uh hep derived you know
cannabinoid products are widely
available from corner stores to your
pharmacies online
yet there isn't really a clear
regulatory framework of that
so the biggest objective of the
cannabinoid program is to try and
provide some basic rules for what is
allowed for the sale of these type of
products
and then the second bullet here is
really the the big one is establishing
consumer protections and quality control
standards for these cannabinoid products
and you know we really did not try and
reinvent the wheel here in terms of
where these requirements coming from a
lot of them pull from best practices in
the food beverage industry or the
cannabis industry in terms of how to
deal with things like thc and packaging
and labeling and
mandating that all of the processors in
the canada attempt program uh
achieve a good manufacturing practices
audit
and one of the reasons why we are
mandating the gmp audit of a processor's
facilities is because
if this is legalized at the federal
level um that is probably something that
is going to also be authorized because
it is a requirement that exists for
most food beverage or dietary supplement
products that are sold at you know
grocery stores or normal commerce
and then the last goal here or objective
of the program is to educate and enforce
against substandard products or
disallowed forms of cannabinoid hemp
products in the marketplace
as you can imagine because of the way
the market grew there is a lot of
disinformation out there in terms of
what is hemp what is
delta 8 thc
it's a whole new vocabulary
and and really requires a lot of
education out there
but also there's a role for the office
to play to make sure dangerous and
harmful products are not being sold
so there are four um license types under
the cannabinoid hemp program
uh there are two processor licenses one
for extraction and manufacturing and one
for manufacturing only
the
extraction and manufacturing license is
unique in that it allows the processor
to take a biomass
raw hemp and then extract it to create
an intermediary product such as a
isolate a distillate or a crude oil
which then can be used to manufacture a
finished cannabinoid product
the manufacturing only license is
available for a processor who is
purchasing that intermediary product
that distillate or isolate and then
manufacturing a product from it so it
just allows different opportunities for
different business models to
enter the program
there's a couple more requirements on
the extractor side
just because some of the extractor
techniques could require someone to
get more
code compliance or fire code safety
depending on how they are extracting
and then is also a connective
distributor and can android have retail
license
the distributor license
is
only applicable for processors
or distributors who are selling
cannabinoid hemp products manufactured
outside of new york state
and selling them to a new york state
retailer
and really the main reason for this
license is to help the office with uh
enforcement and compliance it's a lot
easier to go after one distributor and
say hey this product you're selling to
100 different retailers is not allowed
versus trying to go to every single
retailer and pulling products off the
shelf or providing education whatever
it'd be
and then the retail license is really
meant to be more of a registration at
this point we're really trying to figure
out who are selling these cannabis
products and providing them with
information for things they should be
looking for when they're sourcing these
products there should be certain things
on the packaging and the labeling there
should be test results
and it's really at this point uh more of
an educational uh
license before
as this program is very still much in
its its early stages
so as i mentioned in the outline
last week governor cathy holcomb signed
a new bill into law for conditional
cultivators
this is a relatively
novel idea as i do not believe any other
state has pursued this
however what the bill authorizes is it
gives the office of cannabis management
the ability to license on previously
authorized hemp growers from the
department of agriculture markets to
start growing cannabis for the upcoming
adult use program
and so uh really the idea here is you
know there's a handful of
people in the state who have experience
growing cannabis which is the same as as
hemp if you're growing for
high cbd content
and because new york
is in the northeast and the growing
season is relatively short this
legislation had to be passed now
in order for any growers to be able to
grow outside or in a greenhouse for the
2020 growth season
so
this program is really just all about
trying to jump start the adult use of
market and the office will be sharing
more information
soon
now it's important to note that not all
previously authorized hemp growers from
the department of pagan markets will be
eligible for this conditional cultivator
license
the legislation sets out the following
parameters in order for an applicant to
be eligible to apply
first they must have been authorized to
grow hemp under the department of ag and
markets industrial hemp research pilot
program
number two they must be in good standing
with the department of agriculture and
markets
number three they must have been
authorized to grow cannabinoid or cbd
hemp
as opposed to growing habit for uh seed
or fiber
number four is they must have grown cbd
for cannabinoid
for two out of the past four years so
that's between 2018 and 2021
and be able to provide documentation to
the office proving that
so i know at one time i think there was
over
700 uh authorized hemp farmers in new
york state however from some harvest
reports and some preliminary information
from ag markets we know many of those
people who were authorized to grow
didn't actually grow
so so this legislation is looking for
cultivators who have experience
actually growing have uh in new york
state
and then lastly uh the last kind of
eligibility criteria is the the
applicant uh must be 51 owned by the
entity or individual who had the
hemp grower license and this is of
course a provision in place to make sure
that someone is not flipping the license
and making sure it goes to the people
who have the experience growing up
so like i said the office is working on
developing guidance and it helps me
sharing more information soon there's
actually some preliminary information on
our website now
under uh cannabis.newyork.gov
licensing
i can provide that link to mary at the
end but it includes an faq as well as a
link to the legislation where i
encourage folks to go check it out um
and like i said we hope to be sharing
more information soon
so what does the conditional adult use
cannabis cultivator license authorize
the license allows a licensee to grow up
to one acre of canopy outdoors
and 25 000 square feet of canopy in a
greenhouse
and a canopy is usually defined as the
area that is actually
plants that are flowering and growing um
it does not include like storage areas
or areas used for processing
harvesting or trimming it really is
focused on the area where plants are
actually
planted
and a cultivator can grow both outdoors
and in a greenhouse so they can be
multiple grow locations however
if they do
choose to do that the greenhouse grow
cannot be more than 20 000 square feet
and
with a maximum of 30 000 square feet
overall
and really the real reason for why
there's different uh square footage
allowed for greenhouse grows versus
outdoor growers is because there's a
more ability for the cultivator to
control the environment in a greenhouse
grow and thus the idea is to try and
make some parity in terms of output
comparing
the outdoor
square footage in the greenhouse square
footage
and the legislation does authorize a
cultivator to use up to 20 artificial
lights
please be aware that the office does
expect to be issuing guidance as it
relates to lighting um we know that you
know high in density and some of the
older lighting methods can be very
energy intensive and we want to make
sure that uh the growers are thinking
about uh sustainability and
environmental requirements so please be
on the lookout for for guidance as it
relates to lighting the legislation
author also
authorizes the minimum processing
manufacturing and distribution of
cannabis flower products for cultivators
please be aware that this does not
include any extraction authorization and
it's limited to uh cannabis flower
products
that uh authorization does expire in
june 1st 2023 so if they wish to
continue that activity they would have
to get a processor or distributor
license
when those do become available
and then lastly
this uh last kind of bullet here is
really important
the legislation mandates that they grow
and comply with all the program terms
conditions regulations and guidance set
out by the cannabis control board and
the office of cannabis management
so because of just the timing of this
bill coming out kind of before the
formal regulation package is finished
from the office of cannabis management
there's going to be a lot of
attestations and terms and conditions
that the growers are going to be
saying that they will adhere to
as they as they kind of launch this
process
so like i said um you know we'll be
sharing more information soon
and
it's a really exciting idea to jumpstart
the adult use industry
and as far as i'm aware i think we're
the only state that has pursued this
opportunity so
it'll be really interesting to see how
it all plays out
i also wanted to touch upon some
proposed regulations that are currently
out for public comment
uh
with the cannabinoid program right now
so on december 16th the cannabis control
board uh voted to file
some changes to the
regulations and
the comment period actually ends march
6th or 7th so if you have any comments
you still have a couple days
to get to the program
the best way to send comments is via
email
and we have an email dedicated to that
it's called regulations
at ocm.newyork.gov
there's also a link to these proposed
regulations on our website
so a lot of these changes came out of uh
comments we actually received during the
last
last regulatory package
and uh instead of reposting for another
set of of uh
comment period we decided to file those
regulations and then
address these changes as a separate
standalone right package
so uh just quickly it allows the
milligram cap for cannabinoids in a
dietary supplement product
per serving to increase from 75 to 100
milligrams
it removes the requirement that
cannabinoid help products be shelf
stable
it uh increases the acceptable thc
concentration of intermediary extract
from three percent thc to five percent
thc
it allows of out-of-state manufacturers
to admit certain warning labels uh
particularly for
products that are broad spectrum or
isolate derived so they do not contain
any thc
it uh
mandates a new definition for craft
cannabis
uh really the goal here is you know
we've been hearing in the market that a
lot of people have been calling
hey sorry that that was me purposely
stopping
um
i i unfortunately do have a hard stop at
uh 2 30 so i wanted to
kind of open it up or at least at least
sometime for questions or comments if
anyone has any
the last few slides which uh just kind
of walk through the application process
and also uh
share some information on how to how to
best contact the uh the office of
cannabis management
i'll let others go i know i have
questions but if others want to shoot
theirs out
i don't hear anybody i'm unmuting so the
the 8084 the new legislation you were
just talking about um i saw the word
distribution a lot so are growers that
get this conditional license going to be
able to sell as well or do they have to
sell to a dispensary who also doesn't
have a license yet correct yeah so the
way the uh cannabis law is structured
is uh
no essentially
entity is allowed to have an interest
in
a retail tier and also the producer tier
so
this license would authorize them to
cultivate to process cannabinoid or
adult use flower products and distribute
adult use flower products to
dispensaries that you correctly pointed
out do not exist yet but not uh to a
customer not a retail sale
okay
so uh the other
big one
is this is
marijuana
that's the word i'm going to use
production
even this uh conditional use is it
agriculture it will it be it will can
folks
uh
get their ag assessment when they plant
it things like that
that's a really great question mary and
i had a town supervisor ask me yesterday
by the way
yeah and i know this comes up uh
sometimes as it relates to to like local
zoning and where these uh places are
zoned
and
particularly at locations that also do
like manufacturing and processing and
grow at the same location there's been a
couple questions there i unfortunately
do not have a good answer for you and
probably need to connect with tim and
some folks over at ag and marcus to
discuss this in more detail
i know hemp was specifically added to
the list of uh
plants that are considered agricultural
in the law
and uh whether or not cannabis would be
considered one um i i think is something
we still need to iron out is that right
tim i think there was some legislation
floating around that would would do that
and i'm not sure uh
i'm not sure what the status of that
bill is i'll try to find out
heather i think um you she posed a
question about
um cbd when because the legislation
specifically says you know processing
and rules and regulations are about um
cbd for
human consumption
so does this include because i know ag
markets gets involved our department of
health gets involved actually in topical
stuff like creams or agave markets does
pet food so all of those non like i'm
not putting in my mouth but it has cbd
in it and has some sort of health thing
who's who's doing that and does it have
to follow all the same rules
yeah so so it's kind of an odd
definition but in the rags human
consumption includes uh
topicals being applied on the skin
however we excluded
uh products that meet the federals
definition the fda's definition of
cosmetics
so if it's marketed and it's not
intended to have a purpose or effect on
the body so if someone's just putting
some in eye cream and they're not saying
like this is gonna cure your
wrinkles or something like that then
that's fine that doesn't need to be uh
under under a cannabinoid hemp program
however if it is saying like if you put
this on it's going to cure your elbow
and it's a you know there's kind of like
a medical thing behind it then it does
fall into the program
okay
uh
the only other thing i'm just gonna
point at is that um i noticed for
out-of-state manufacturers they're
allowed to admit something omit on their
label
so and you know i'm taking the extension
hat off maybe a little bit here but and
i know there's processors and growers it
wasn't the whole idea of a lot of this
legislation was to level the playing
field
and so now to allow out-of-state
manufacturers and i'm not finding fault
with you i'm just pointed out and that
the others on the on the this might want
to do something about it and that now
out of state manufacturers don't have to
follow particular rules that now in
state do
that makes the lev the play that
unlevels the playing field
yeah and actually that particular one it
was previously we had it where
out-of-state manufacturers were actually
uh not able to do a certain uh label
requirement this actually leveled the
playing field so it treats all
processors the same and that that change
was uh there's a warning on the
cannabinoid hemp labels that's required
if it is a full spectrum product that
includes trace amounts of thc however if
they have a lab test and say that it's
either uh from an isolate or a broad
spectrum product and it proves that
there's no thc in it they then do not
have to include that warning yeah yeah
but i'm so sorry i actually i literally
have another presentation sorry no no
problem no problem um thank you it was
really nice to be here and i'm sure
we'll talk soon
thank you take care
anybody else have any other questions
for tim or you know i can get them off
to patrick
if
we're working on some
kind of a quick and easy bulleted
version
of this conditional
permitting so that people can understand
it better about what it does and does
not provide producers
hopefully that'll be ready in a few days
and i can start getting it out and about
i do want to plug in put a plug in for
the blog so ny hemp exchange
that's we called hemp exchange because
as i mentioned earlier we
i'd started it as folks could you know
buy and sell and sort of match make a
little bit that hasn't been the most
successful part the
more successful part has been the news
section
so um when when it's ready it'll be up
on there and if you're not currently uh
getting or if you haven't been to that
blog and sort of signed up for it to get
the push notifications when i throw
something on there you might want to do
that
[Music]
tim do you have any last
anything
because of
no i i think i'm good i would just
for any of you who know hemp growers
that were in the program last year um
tell them they need a new license
we've so far gotten i think i approved
the 90th one today
so
out of seven hundred and some you
haven't
the highest we ever were at was eight
twenty and i didn't expect to get back
to that in the first year by any stretch
but actually i'm a little bit ahead of
where i thought we'd be right now but uh
there are a lot of people who have not
yet uh applied for their licenses who
i'm fairly certain they're gonna going
to want to
continue to grow
so
that's
my only word of caution now is make sure
you have a license before you're
planting this year
yeah
and it's going to take a while because
like you mentioned there's background
checks and other stuff that people have
to do now they didn't have to do yeah
that's a new wrinkle but uh i've had a
couple people tell me just in the last
week or so that they when they went to
the post office to get their
fingerprints
i think they started the process before
you know they said the whatever has to
go to the fbi they actually had their
background checks
in their email when they got home
so the fbi was turning around really
fast
i assume those are people who didn't
have a rap sheet
or bad fingerprints right i got a phone
call from somebody who's having a lot of
trouble with their fingerprints yeah i i
had uh somebody who
said that their fingerprints just were
not working out um
if you do decide to do a hard copy and
nail it into the fbi that's taking weeks
so
if you can do it electronically i would
encourage that
all right so if anybody else has any
other questions
i'm gonna let everybody go i want to
thank you for your extra 15 minutes of
your time and don't forget um there's a
session evaluation link that kim just
put in the chat box
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu